nous considérons cette assignation comme
la posture du mépris du président du
conseil exécutif vis-à-vis de ses
personnels parce que nous considérons
que nous étions dans une action
la mobilisation s'amplifie et les
personnages qui ont une cote de plus en
plus ils doivent se manifester contre la
désorganisation mise en place par le pc
nous réclamons le retour à l'emploi pour
les trente deux autres salariés qui
n'ont pas été reprises sur les 41 et
aujourd'hui nous estimons que c'est une
situation que nous devons continuer à
défendre parce que c'est à l'arrière
sont des salariés méritants et qui n'ont
aucune raison d'avoir été mises à la
vente